hello everyone this is amir
from audio science review
we're uh back to school again uh this
time and not a very dense topic but
uh quite non-intuitive if you read my uh speaker
reviews you see there's always a statement at the
beginning this is all the listening tests
are performed in mono many people quickly
dismiss the results then saying what the hell
is this guy doing who listens to speakers one
at a time and therefore everything he says
must be wrong he doesn't know what he's doing
uh i do know what i'm talking and it's not my idea
it builds on decades of research in this area that
demonstrates why mono listening is much more
useful and powerful in determining the fidelity
of a speaker than stereo or multi-channel so i
thought i covered the literature in this area
is the kind of information where uh most
audiophiles don't seem to be aware of at
all the information is is not readily available
to them and so everybody just goes by they light
intuition that uh it's all about you know two
speakers and imaging and all these aspects so
let's go over that and uh let me start
with uh where the research started uh
almost uh 40 years ago 1983 uh 38 years ago
the research was performed by Dr. Floyd Toole
when he was part of the doing research at national
research council in canada the canadian government
had built this research institute to help the
local industry in canada you know advance their
knowledge and competitiveness in the world
and one area they had was audio research and
that's where companies like paradigm anthem
psp and others started all canadian companies
so dr floyd Toole went there and did a lot of
study of of you know what speaker people prefer
and why but also one of the things he did was that
comparing stereo versus mono listening clearly
doing stereo testing is a lot more time consuming
than doing mono testing especially if you want to
do a blind test where you want to switch speakers
switching two speakers is much more difficult than
switching just one speaker so uh he wanted to
find out if if uh you know what the difference
was between the two um the paper is you know
being old it's kind of hard to read so i've
just cut and pasted a few sections of it uh
i encourage you if you want to read it to uh
go and and uh download the paper from audio
engineering society or you can get uh dr floyd
Tool's superb book sound reproduction in rooms
and he goes over all these things in there also
but anyway i'm going to quickly summarize the key
points of of the present of the paper they had
the same uh four speakers but organized in two
separate uh rooms one is that they were tested
as as a mono one at a time and they they were not
swapping them they were just you know positioning
very close together so you had a slight angle
error but otherwise you know you could just switch
between a b and c and d for stereo they actually
put them on two turntables and they would rotate
the turntables and get the two uh speakers to
align and then same listening tests would be
performed the payback goes through great lengths
in the content they use these were exceptionally
well recorded uh concert uh recordings of
different types with you know multiple mics and
just stereo mics and you can read about that in
the paper so this was kind of content that you
know was designed for this kind of testing uh
for both uh imaging testing and also tonality
i'll jump right to the conclusion of
the paper because it's most important
but before i do they it's always useful in these
tests to have a control which is uh something that
you know in advance to be lousy they have three
speakers all three of them were hardly you know
well rated in previous testing research they had
done but they also picked this other speaker dd
that had this really bad subjective and objective
results and i'm showing you the objective
frequency response measurement on the right look
at how it has this you know just bases up here
goes up and then it takes a nosedive and then
the rest of the level it doesn't even match the
woofer in there so clearly a screwed up uh you
know two-way design of some sort and off-axis
is terrible so they had this terrible speaker um
when they tested in mono the three speakers sort
of ranked one two and three you can see they're
clustered together and confirmed that what they
already knew which is these speakers rated well
but with this equality from four to eight or nine
in here vertically higher is the better car is
better um and that look at speaker dd in manual
testing it indeed you know finished a lot worse in
these things there's no question that the speaker
that we knew in advance was bad was bad but
look at what happens when we switch to stereo
first the three speakers maintain their rankings
one two and three is essentially one two and
three here so whether we're testing a mono stereo
didn't make a difference their rankings were both
for all three were very positive and very high
but also their separation was also more or less
the same there's some degree of error in all these
tests they're subjective after all so don't you
know micro focus into this thing but essentially
he they're similar to each other but look at what
happened to speaker dd all of a sudden when
they were testing stereo the same listeners
weren't so bothered by this crummy speaker
and they rated it much closer to the uh
the three much better designed speakers so clearly
the listeners were fooled by the stereo effect
and what speaker that should have
been easy to rate as being terrible
became much harder so and the speakers were
good you know stereo versus mono didn't make
a difference speaker that was bad became more
forgiven in in this uh you know stereo testing
um a lot of people say well that's
the frequency response because
it's not everything how about stereo imaging how
can we measure stereo imaging and i'm not going
to get into how we can measure there are a lot of
factors involved there but uh this test actually
went after that and it's called spatial quality
spatial means two-dimensional three-dimensional
beyond a point source it's a technical term you'll
see me use it a lot instead of just saying stereo
imaging that which you know has uh you know
it's not as technically correct term and uh
here they tested again uh stereo versus mono and
this time they were asking them in this column
on the left is the sound quality on the right
they were asking them um what do you how do you
rate the spatial quality of of this speaker and
uh in mono look at that we got one two and then
the third one is way the heck down here so and
very nice separation between these three speakers
but look at when we look at the exact same
three speakers in stereo look at this they're
clustered right together and listeners could no
longer determine the spatial quality of those
speakers relevant relative to each other here
everybody thinks if you put two speakers in a room
you'll be able to hear the imaging a lot
better than if you do mono now you might be
saying what the hell is he talking about what
is mano's imaging there's absolutely imaging
and indeed that was brought out in here that
this speaker the reason it was rated so low
was that when listeners were listening blind by
the way all these are blind listening with the
curtain in front they thought this speaker
sounded like an artificial point source
or like a clock radio or whatever it's just
that was not pleasing to them whereas uh
these other speakers they have a softer halo and
and imaging around the speaker it was not a point
source which does not sound like reality you know
in real life if you were listening to me i'm not
coming out of this one little point in my mouth
there's a halo of sound that i'm generating even
though i'm in mono listen to somebody speaking
in a church they don't sound like a little point
source there's an imaging there's a halo around
them and and so speakers most definitely have
that why do they have that because they sound they
send sound to the walls and that's a delayed sound
and it comes back and generates a halo around the
speaker and actually pulls the speaker's image uh
and that makes it sort of wider image so it's
not in one spot so clearly uh we were able
to determine that a lot better that a speaker
that wasn't very good at that and provided this
artificial point source of sound was rated low
in mono but in stereo it was again a crapshoot
both on fidelity which i've already talked about
on the left and spatial quality all the speakers
were thought to be the same whereas you look in
here you can see the wide variation one and two
were good speakers and the third one was not and
it's the same third one in here that didn't do
well in imaging either and you know everything's
spaced out apart and we have better discrimination
of the fidelity of this speaker both in
tonal quality and imaging on this now
you might say well that's an old study well it
was but the same set of people that worked at nrc
spread out through the universe of of audio Dr
Floyd Toole and and uh dr olive uh landed at
harman um some of the others landed at paradigm
and and PSB and so forth and uh while at harmon
they uh did a lot of uh studying of this also
because again it's very time consuming to
do testing in in mono version stereo and this
paper was published um years later 2008 and it
wasn't directly a test of this in that the paper's
overall thesis is about the new kind of room
equalization that harman was developing and in
the process they also tested it to see how well it
performed in mono testing stereo testing and 5.1
multi-channel testing i'll show you this room that
i've been at in Harman this is a purpose-built
room uh complies with IEC spec which is uh what a
standard listening room should be there's a paper
on this also an AES if you want to read from Sean
Olive go through all the details but essentially
excuse me there's a multi-channel system over here
you can see the speakers spread out in here
and they show the speeds and feeds of that
so what was the outcome there so they were
testing different algorithms for uh room eq
and comparing it to doing nothing so no eq means
the speakers were playing as is with no no change
no equalization then they had uh three different
algorithms they were applying one is based on
predicted in-room response and in-situ and direct
i won't get into one what those are maybe one
day i'll cover room equalization later uh in the
future but for now just know that think of these
as like three separate speakers or three different
sound signatures because equalization changes the
sound and uh listeners were listening to all
of these in multi-channel or in stereo or mono
first let's start with multi-channel which is
this sort of this white box with x towards it
notice that all four methods were the same
so doing nothing was the same as doing
something with this algorithm or this algorithm
or maybe a little bit better with this algorithm
but essentially if you look at the error bars
listeners said yeah i don't know what this eq
is doing or not doing and when you change
the algorithm it also sounded the same
and so in multi-channel they couldn't
tell the difference between them
even though the algorithms technically were very
different then it switched to stereo and that's
this red line over here uh with a little triangle
on it and look at what happened all of a sudden
all the algorithms did better than doing no eq
which is this this this line over here so all of a
sudden doing nothing is worse than doing something
uh so it's a gap develop but look at what happens
when you go to do a mono test and so you're
only testing one speaker all of a sudden wow
the listeners were like yeah maybe when you switch
on the eq look at the sound quality improvement we
went all the way up to six from down to uh three
scores so massive improvement in this algorithm
and similar improvement in in both of these other
schemes although the first scheme was superior
so this clearly proved this is a controlled
double-blind testing and just played by the book
in a room that's designed to be repeatable and
verifiable papers have been written peer-reviewed
and you know read by millions of people and that
100 percent was the outcome so this confirms again
a study that was done years and years back some
20 years before and exact same conclusion now
people say well maybe harman does this because
they don't they can't do a multi-channel
listening test and therefore they decided to
do a you know mono is cheaper and easier to do
that's what they're doing they're being lazy
well that's not the case because if you go read
other publications from Harman you see that
they're very proud of this room that they built
called the Harman multi-channel listener room
(MLL) and what that is is that it's a room
where you can set up a full surround system of
two different sets of speakers and it will shuffle
all of them simultaneously so you can listen to
one set of speakers in multi-channel and then by
pressing a button a few seconds later using these
hydraulic lifts all these speakers go back and
forth and a new set is presented to you and you
can see a better shot of it over here where you
know the speakers are sitting here and and they're
all shuffled or not so harman has this room but
they don't use it hardly anymore or if they use it
they only use it for mono testing because it just
the results aren't there and so i've gone
to Harman twice and both times i've taken
the double blind test of speakers and this is
one time picture that i took when i was there
and it's a much smaller room so much cheaper
to build and it only shuffles one speaker at
a time so this speaker right now is Martin
Logan that's in the front there's B&W over
there and there's a JBL and they shuffle in
and out randomly and a random piece of music
plays and you have a scoring sheet where you give
score and i'll tell you when you're sitting there
the job is difficult as it is when you're
evaluating speakers it's not an easy job because
still takes three or four seconds for speakers
to change and then tonality completely changes
and you've got to judge and you've
got to score these speakers so
everything we can do to simplify the job we need
to do we don't want to make the job so difficult
for a subjective evaluator listener when they're
giving us you know mishmash we should watch the
answers we want to make it simple as we can
and nothing does that more than that i tell
you when i was sitting there listening blind i
had no idea what was behind there they'd never
even told us what the speakers were and you'd
hear the speakers like this martin logan had a
massively different sound signature than all the
others and uh you know in that regard the job was
simpler so what is it net out to look this is not
a new idea if you if you haven't heard about it
shame on you not on me or the researchers this
goes back you know 40 years 38 years dr Floyd
Toole has been talking about this in forums and
articles and interviews in his book that's been
out almost eight to ten years it's just there's no
excuse to not know about it now admittedly you all
consume content from the same usual sources of you
know typical you know reviewers what have you and
or your buddies that aren't exposed to the proper
science never seen these papers and everything
your gut will say hey look you know you got to do
this testing in in uh in stereo or multi-channel
and so i can't blame you fully but from here
on i will blame you because this research is
ironclad it's solid i've done this testing i've
done mono versus stereo and i'm telling you
mono is just the way to tell you can hear the
tonality you can hear what is wrong with the
speaker why is this the fact that you know stereo
is not as good um i have a theory which is what
i call beauty of of of stereo multi-channel um
stereo obviously sounds a lot nicer than the mono
speaker does a multi-channel even more sounds are
coming all the way around you i think the moment
we we do that there um the brain it just gets
so much enjoyment out of that spatial quality
that it gets lost and can't focus on what's
happening number one number two there's masking
that's happening so if you have a frequency
response error in one speaker but the second
one is playing the other channel it can ride on
top of this one and you can't tell the difference
between you know two speakers is accurately
because you're listening to a mix of speakers
and it homogenizes things there are different
locations in the room so you don't want to do that
i i used to lead engineering for broadcast video
companies and would sell to the major networks and
and uh post production studios and others and
uh if you look at the professional monitor they
always have a button that goes to black and
white instead of color and you we brought our
you know effect systems and others installed
the major network let's say ESPN or CNN or
what have your BBC and the first thing they would
do put the picture in black and white and look
for artifacts because in color same effect happens
the color fools your eye is pretty is nice but the
resolution and the acuity of the eye is higher in
black and white so they would instantly turn off
the color with a button on a broadcast monitor and
then they would find artifacts and issues they're
like oh what's this ring in the air why is you
know what is timing wrong in here same thing here
we go to mono because we want to turn off the
beauty of stereo stereo is an effect produced
in production of music the two speakers have no
communication with each other it's not like they
play differently because the other one was
turned on also and we don't want that we want
to know is the speaker properly engineered
does it produce the right fidelity and then
yes when you use it you listen to two if you
want i've had at least one person online on
audio science review that actually did this
one from stereo and he had multiple speakers
he was evaluating and he switched to mono
and came reported right back he says wow
it was a lot easier and it's amazing that you
know i'm one of the few people who still does this
it's like hardly anybody outside of Harman seems
to be doing this you know mono testing it just
amazes me uh i go to shows and everybody's
sitting there pontificating what the sound is
whether sound is good or bad listen to two
channels yeah of course it's hard so you're
gonna sit there and pontificate whether you know
the system sounds good or not switch to mono
it's easier it's cheaper it's more convenient
in my case i only get one speaker to ship back
and forth to me there's a lot of expense and
a hassle involved in shipping two speakers
back and forth for testing by shipping one speaker
we save half the cost half to storage have the
main handling and set up and everything so of
course every other reviewer out there is doing
stereo testing and he keeps talking about imaging
and everything which is function of the content
and by the way also functional frequency response
and they're just lost in the woods that's why they
keep talking about this nebulous stuff that just
does not matter you know we want to know if the
speaker is high fidelity or it's not high fidelity
they need to switch to mono you can't keep putting
your head in the sand saying oh you know i've got
two ears therefore i gotta listen to two speakers
now if you want you can do a secondary test in
stereo nobody's stopping you but start with mono
properly evaluate the sound of a speaker then go
if you want to listen to two channels good luck
because by the way those two channels they're room
specific what imaging they create so half the time
they're probably talking about the you know what's
happening in their room versus what's happening
you know with speaker alone and
that's what we want to do um
one key thing to remember is that you know
when we use measurements they're 100 accurate
because there are measurements right i don't
mean in in that they answer something but the
objective the machine measures something you can
measure and measure and measure and we can just
touch and feel that measurement and sell it when
we use human subjects they're so variable we want
to turn them into instruments really that's what
our use is we want to turn them into soldiers of
that just we could just stick in front of speakers
say spit out one to ten numbers say how good
the speaker is and we're gonna help that human
listener become more reliable training makes it
more reliable knowledge makes them more reliable
and mono listening for speaker makes that listener
more reliable they're now able to tell differences
even if they're not professionally trained
they have a better shot of hearing what the
speaker does and as i've explained even though
it's non-intuitive you absolutely have imaging
with a single speaker when you have one speaker
reflects of the wall it creates a mirror image
on the other side and the speaker actually
uh us use the word smear but it's smearing a good
way that this image shifts it literally called uh
image shift of a speaker and becomes a wider
thing that's why for center speakers you want to
have white dispersion because then you can hit
the side walls and stretch that center speaker
to be the width of your tv or projection
screen you don't want that sound to come
out of one little point in the middle of the
screen because the action is on the entire uh
uh display itself but that's for the topic um but
just know that these things are important you know
the tonality of a single speaker is important
and the things that we cover there's a reason i
do what i do don't go around you know especially a
lot of them are just reading some tonight somebody
was calling me a hack because he said that he
just tested mono there we go i've rested my case
well no you're a hack if you haven't spent five
seconds asking you know somebody that knows hey
why is uh you know why mono testing is better
clearly i'm not a stupid idiot that woke up in the
morning and said i'm just gonna start listening
in mud and when the world thinks it should be
in stereo there's a reason for it and it happens
to be fortuitous that we can do this testing in
mono it actually works better and uh you know it's
it's been proven there's just no doubt about this
and and uh no speaker goes from bad in mono
to great and stereo it just hasn't happened
you know the rankings that existed mono also
exists in stereo we're just as listeners or we're
less picky on this thing and by the way that's
why a lot of you aren't disgusted with speakers
you own that i measure and i say they're no good
because you're listening to them in stereo you're
much less critical in stereo and if you listen
to a multi-channel that's why bose made a living
selling these little acoustic tiny little crappy
speakers because it was multi-channel and that
multi-channel effect is just so captivating you
know those 5.1 speaker setups that are usually
you know bottom of the line designs and cost
but you set them up in a multi-channel system
they sound nice because the content steals
the show and convinces you to sound good
but you know if you want to know what's
a good speaker you want to start with the
you know proper analysis and if you can't do it
i'm doing it for you just don't go around saying
you know the guy's an idiot doing uh mono testing
i stand on the shoulders of pretty tall people
in doing what i do okay hopefully you uh could
follow this again these papers are available
i'll create a thread on audio science review
uh website if you want to come and discuss
these things i can code more from the papers
and and you know prove this point for you but
this should be enough please don't question it
you're questioning the ABCs of proper controlled
listening tests for speakers how you're supposed
to do that okay see you in a future video bye-bye